نحن نتعلم للتو أن محامية
لمحرر التلفزيون الروسي أه
المرأة الشقراء التي تراها على شاشتك
هناك امرأة رفعت تلك اللافتة المناهضة للحرب
أثناء بث مباشر يوم
الاثنين أكد محاموها الآن أن
CNN كانت موجودة في  موسكو ،
لقد كان مجرد موقف شجاع رائع
لساعات ،
مكان وجودها ، كانت موظفة المحطة غير معروفة
أثناء البث ، حملت لافتة
كتب عليها لا للحرب ، أوقف الحرب ، لا
تصدق الدعاية التي يقولون لك كذبة
، لقد سجلت هذه الرسالة قبل
ذلك الاحتجاج مباشرة
ما يحدث الآن في أوكرانيا
جريمة وروسيا هي الدولة المعتدية
والمسؤولية عن هذا
العدوان تقع على ضمير
شخص واحد فقط هذا الرجل هو فلاديمير
بوتين اذهب إلى المسيرات ولا
تخافوا لأنهم لا يستطيعون القبض علينا جميعاً.